a long time ago I was a child playing
video games one of the best parts about
video games was the ability to modify
the game change how it works changed the
way the game was played changed the
exact type of game that you played
eventually modding got so involved that
you didn't recognize what you were
playing in the first place and along
came those few gems that were just
delightful pieces of mods that made the
experience totally worth it what the
[Music]
if that song doesn't date when this was
made then I don't know what does this is
scientists slaughterhouse now this game
or this modification of a game is off of
the original half-life engine which was
made back in 1998 this mod was made in
the early 2000s I believe and its entire
objective is about slaughtering the
scientists in the game I absolutely love
this and the game was discontinued which
is a goddamn shame well maybe it's not
maybe it's not stupid fun I haven't
played this in years but what I remember
of it is that it was just absolutely
wonderful if you like the idea of those
whacking games and the gratuitous
violence that comes with it then you
will like this game because that's all
it is
I swear that's all it is you can shut up
okay there we go
now oh my god number one it's not even
in the right resolution hang on let me
do this real quick all right so if you
don't know what this is and if you don't
know what half-life is there's I'm sorry
oh hi hello there's really nothing I
could do to explain what it is oh yeah
Oh power me up baby I'll give it a juice
yeah I love the energy armors suck yeah
okay alright yeah here we go yeah it's
just that this is literally in
that's a list it's just a game with an
entire infinite possibility of different
ways that you can annihilate scientists
from the game half-life that's it
any matter pond gun any matter cobra
alright okay so yes Oh shooty shooty
shooty shooty shooty yeah oh I forgot
that there were scientists under the
elevator it's been so long since I
played this particular quote unquote
game now I can knocking long jump yeah I
forgot they were okay yes so if you
thought that was it oh you just have one
gun and that's gonna be it
the answer is no whoa whoa oh okay you
can shut down thank you okay what is
this do I forget incendiary warhead Oh
envy you say MVP
you shouldn't run into that my bud
alright so half-life is an old game oh
where am i oh I forgot there's a lot of
loading the games old so like you know
how loading screens and engines didn't
used to be a thing it kind of is now
look at that sky Baja seem to be on an
aircraft carrier of some shirts I'm sure
this is normal wait hang on let me line
up the crosshairs hello that was fun
test fire Oh goodbye alright go go buddy
go go come on there you go are you good
oh [ __ ]
I don't think I was supposed to do that
I'm not sure how I get back now there
goes supposed to fall in oh [ __ ] okay
well that's weird
is there a load there we go okay back
here I guess no this is fine moving on
to a different area because that's not
where we want this piece button Oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh I see oh yeah
you should be worried oh I see oh I see
god I miss half life half life was this
[ __ ] I'm gonna say it outright half life
was this [ __ ] one of my favorite games
of all time
love the imagination and my god valve
what are you doing what are you doing
half-life 3 you got to do it at some
point you can't leave us all hanging
forever here man
whoa that's a that's a quake portal
hello what's going on in there
oh I don't look good well I don't look
good at all
probably one of those not good things oh
hi don't walk into the beam don't walk
into the vine well you're not gonna want
get into the beam are you hey you
shouldn't walk into this beam here whoa
okay what's in here excuse me Oh
disruptive shield avoid contact
oh hi buddy hey how you doing I lost my
jump assist I lost it so goodly all
right uh-oh yeah yeah yeah oh well
that's not what I wanted that's not what
I wanted at all can I get another one
please pretty please put another
scientist on the platform please and
squoosh I shouldn't be laughing at that
I should but that's what this game does
to you oh well that's what this mod does
to you
it gives you a feeling of godly power
the kinds that you shouldn't actually
have and yet you do and I know not why I
enjoy it so Oh what is this
it's a flamethrower it's literally just
a flamethrower and then there's a part
away huh oh wait
why are you fine I'll stay here yes oh
let are you leaving me what a baby where
did you go oh oh I didn't do that
that wasn't even me okay caution extreme
heat keep clear what am i launching whoa
oh [ __ ] whoops bye be careful you guys
better be careful you guys better be
careful I think I'm getting Wallops
about the volcano if I'm not mistaken oh
oh oh oh my god
that's why I should not have power in
case it wasn't obvious I should not have
I just should all right let's get me out
of here I've taken a bit of damage I
don't want to do too much else damage to
my poor innocent body oh hi how are you
how are you doing not so good apparently
according to your stump of a head now
what's funny about this game is it got
more sophisticated the longer it went on
like the more they updated the game the
more sophisticated it became no one
conquers the world alone for us nothing
is impossible like it seems weird to say
but yeah the game did in fact become a
lot more sophisticated a scammer
I don't like the sound of that okay
alright oh they just vanish oh they just
go into the ether oh they just disappear
out of this universe was this dude
what does this button do alright so
that's pretty standard okay
alright everyone do the flop all right
so cool good yeah so Nephilim oh [ __ ]
Nephilim wave oh right they're all so
dancey they're excited the lure of of
half-life is also just as bizarre as
sometimes the game thinking about the
headcrabs and all that stuff and the
combine and all hey hey buddy green and
mentor oh wait please don't mess with my
laser turret oh I wouldn't
[Applause]
how about you buddy g-man g-man all
right whatever just back to you buddy
all right all your base are belong to us
you have no chance to survive make your
time
all right good great yeah good hey
shaadi Gunny what does this do
oh I'll save you I tried what I'm sorry
hey you didn't tell me that was gonna
happen man I got so many memories of
playing half-life so many memories I
can't even explain to you how far this
brings me back because it really really
does oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
what does it do what it's just to kill
you it's a kill you Oh what the hell
whoa I bugged it I I most certainly
loved it I bugged it that's not supposed
to happen that's that's not that's not
what you want oh no oh yeah come with me
[Music]
baby I'm back oh where am I going baby
I'm back mom oh [ __ ]
Oh what is this I know what this is
there's a weird alien bug launcher which
I love power overwhelming a weight fuel
oh oh I get it
oh I know what you want you want me to
set up a bunch of things for you to get
this to under waiver do this the thing
in the stuff and that the thing you got
it oh wow Snorks snark I'm back baby
whoa [ __ ] wait no no no go back I gotta
get power overwhelming there we go
what have I done Oh oh [ __ ] oh that
that's probably not good for the
scientists outside it is loud out there
it is really loud it's it's quite loud
oh [ __ ]
oh my god Oh weird weird oh they're
fighting each other oh [ __ ] it's a war
alright cool goods war its war I like
war not really but okay I'm out of here
oh okay good good okay save what's
fantastic about mods and I kind of want
to get back into the world of modding
especially modding way too much in games
which is always fun but the best thing
about mods is it allows you to get more
value out of individual games you know
you can have half-life 2 but it can last
you a long
long time because so many people are in
the community are making cool things
like it just kind of never ends whoo
that don't make the most sense but
whatever all right what else we have
here what's this kaboom oh [ __ ] what did
i do see this is what it means it get
more sophisticated as time went on this
this mod was like updated month by month
and so whenever they like added a new
release to it hey you know they would do
this [ __ ] for totally for free and it
would just make game for the love of
like making [ __ ] and I and I love that I
love that it's not sustainable in any
way because people got to eat but man I
love hobbyist mod makers that's the
coolest stuff it's just so fun it just
makes it all really really fun and it
makes games more fun because you can
feel the community that's all a part of
it and you could feel how many people
are like loving the game and enjoying
the game and just like hey there's
something on your shirt hey your face
landed on you where are you turns out
they're all dead okay cool I didn't
realize it was like a wall of fire
approaching you oh my god oh my one more
chin dead Oh Nani that's still going on
out there okay bear that's I guess
that's just forever now can I go turn
that off because that is obsessively too
loud oh my god thank you yes thank you
thank good God who vomited who yakked no
emotion dear do alright oh my Wilma oh
oh
what Millie your face Oh
oh my god I love it I love it really did
get more sophisticated as time went on
that I don't even remember that maybe I
stopped playing before it was this one
okay one Oh there that goes okay good
to potty
good stuff guys good stuff like the ones
spinning on the platform way Oh what is
this lab coats to kill alright sure
whatever you said oh yeah
wow this this is not a tank this is this
is infinitely oh my god oh my god I'm
dead
alright cool web why am I here wait a
minute that's not fair we gotta get out
of there oh my god hey hey hey
holy [ __ ] it's turned on me wait no
that's not fair oh god oh god let me out
of the crazy ride Wow can't make it at
the door oh god oh god oh god stop stop
stop stop stop stop oh geez m's let's uh
turn you off okay
oh alright
hello Oh No close all the trash
compactors on the detention level
Oh God not the trash compactors on the
detention level and smooshy there's just
so many different ways Oh what is this
oh you're gonna love my nuts oh you're
gonna love my nuts
Oh slept up for days you're gonna love
my nuts oh and good the dumps the body
parts right down into the drain that's
so good in fact just waste good yeah
let's get that flow control up please
all right good yeah there oh okay oh
good drown yes that's good that's
perfect okay all right now let's do
squish about safety hood oh yes for
safety if you I want the safety
definitely okay good good I'm out of
here
my god they're so much more to this than
I remember there's legitimately so much
more to this hi buds Oh bah bah
oh hey buds okay bye-bye
oh it's whack-a-mole it'sit's a game a
wacky moments came a wacky it's a
horrible game oh yeah yes you're on
buddy
well this looks fun stop machine before
making adjustments all right oh good
it's slow very oh it's it's just a
little slow very Oh for everybody to
enjoy
doink okay what are we okay yeah yeah
basically that's a weird one cuz
basically it just explodes out I'm gonna
get really happy and jiggly when they do
it oh hi
okay let's go up we very fun now that's
that's cool oh hi okay so I'm gonna be
let into the blue base but then what
what does that mean for me Oh
oh my god okay I'm out of here see you
guys oh hey and nobody's gonna get
through ever again okay good good you
know and go oh hello sorry there's
probably not a whole lot more left to
the game because I don't know what other
ways you could possibly slaughter
scientists but uh I think we might be
reaching close to the end here
oh good at HEV okay brutes control Oh
boots wait no I need to cross that I
need it
I need to cross that please thank you
okay goodbye
I need that thank you thank you thank
you thank you for that I mean it's a
scientist fault for just spawning out of
nowhere like if they didn't just pop out
of existence like that then they
wouldn't have nearly the problem that
they're at it oh all right I'm in here
now wherever here is and there's this
thing oh no wait no there's no one in
there oh all right okay you could still
surprise me every once in a while you
could still give me the old woofer oh
hey is this gonna go spiraling out of
control as the Rams over those
scientists over there can I get up here
please thank you good look out it's like
this scene from Austin Powers you know
how it was I don't need to quote it for
you
all right good road glad I glad I did
that that was worth of the journey I'm
sorry who's dying I'm I'm sorry oh
you're just standing in the middle of
the road well that's not that's not
that's that okay well that debts not
what do you want to see okay goodbye yay
where is this this looks fun oh oh [ __ ]
what did I just do what two three
oh oh oh my god what the hell it's grunt
aged grunt oh they're fight
oh they're dying they're not fighting
that's a massacre oh yeah they're
getting annihilated by that alien or
whatever that is
put some lab coats in there oh I don't
know if I want to go out there
oh boy what did I just do oh it's
following the view of okay all right
good great yeah yeah I'm just gonna
sneak on by right this just slipping by
poor god this is in the door okay so the
door is the door is the door is it or
made it everything's hunky and
everything is dory hey it's raining Wow
good that's cool what is that what is
that that is what what am I looking at
what's going on here is that a Zeppelin
is that gonna kill people up yeah well
it yeah okay yep it'sit's to death okay
that is a new one I gotta admit that is
most certainly a new and do doom balloon
that is so much better than the name
that I came up with that is infinitely
better than death Zeppelin that the doom
balloon that makes so much sense it
hurts
alright cool goodbye how is there more
oh hi oh all right goodbye the first one
that had the brains to run away thank
you oh thank you you know whenever I
played the game I never realized that
the scientists could heal you until way
way after like my 15th playthrough hey
look out behind you all right what is
this oh hey buddy sir Fitz access not
sure what that's doing or what this is
gonna do
take off and lint take off oh here we go
oh we're going oh I've got a UFO I have
I have a UFO I've got a new foe oh my
god oh my god let's go to warp baby warp
it up I don't know where we're going
I've no idea I love this so much by the
way oh my god I'm in space
Oh God why are you up why are you out
there what what the mothership it's a
god damn mothership this is this is the
beauty of Maude's
this is the absolute beauty of Maude's
this is there is nothing better than a
mod that the Creator just takes to the
limit of their imagination this is what
is this oh yes like The BFG or something
like that
okay all right well sorry buddies okay
all right good sorry okay see ya around
it is oh man Red Team only huh
fortunately visit the edge of the map
but you can't really go to the red
sector can you oh no are we approaching
the end oh no we are aren't we
okay good a blue team a any scientists
out there whoa low grav okay
[Music]
Earth Zen let's go to earth oh [ __ ] oh
hey I'm back
what no no no no no no no no no no I
want to go back no I wanted to go back
where did I last save okay here all
right good great good all right
everybody hold on to your hats I just
need to go to Zen cuz that's the way
forward the way I went was going
backwards and I don't want to go
backwards I want to go forward cuz
forwards the only way that I know to go
oh never mind that that doesn't sound
like the way that I wanted to go oh this
door died there's a door I didn't see
the door before I didn't see the door
before I thought that it wasn't a door
all right here we go
this looks prime on fire in this very
slow this is very slow
oh okay goodbye ice powers oh I love it
I butthole I love it even more
I don't know what this is - are you
fighting me oh you wanna fight oh you
were you gonna die that's what you gonna
do just fire do make concern could you
please go practice your beam attacks
somewhere else
this platform is small enough without
you blowing holes in it
hi yeah I don't think so whoopsies
that's not where I wanted to go okay
butthole Oh what do we have here where
are we whoa I'm back home I made it let
it go in one night hi it's me don't
worry don't know why they're letting me
through but they sure aren't they
everything's good in my book
everything's great in my neighborhood
hmm okay there doesn't seem to be
anything else new here he's gotta be
something over here well that's not well
congratulations you've gone where no
players gone before it as will reward
the nephilim alliances giving you
residents of this bio organic waste
storage chamber game over
next time don't go this far the next
level won't be there until the next
version of
scientists slaughterhouse no that's the
end game over man anyway I played this a
lot more than I thought I was going to
and I guess that just goes to show like
how fun it can be enough fun mods can be
in general this is just really silly and
weird and kind of just bizarre and
meaningless but hey that's kind of the
point of mods like they're they're cool
sometimes in there they're wonderful and
they're weird and I like that about them
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you've got favourite mods
that you've played in the past or that
you're playing right now for whatever
game please let me know down in the
comments below I want to know what mods
you guys go to all the time to have some
fun with games that you know and love
and have played a bajillion times and
you know mods make them a little more
fun and you can always go back to it for
a little bit longer so you know that's
pretty cool so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know he thought
down the comments and as always I will
see you
[Music]
you